Up until now, we've been assuming a connection between related individuals. It's
a rather fundamental assumption. So fundamental, we don't even know we do it.
>> Well, that's because it goes without saying. At some point,
we all had to have a biological mother and a biological father.
>> And this is true. But for our purposes, it's important to make
[INAUDIBLE].
An explicit connection about the traits we share as a
family as well as the genetic component that we also
share. Here are two pictures of my parents, my biological
mom and my biological dad. Take a look at both
and which do you think I look most like? Do
you think I look more like my mom or more
like my dad? Oh, Matt, that's a tough one. I
think I'm going to have to go with your mom, though.
>> Yeah, I think so, too.
Outside of our appearance, though, we may identify with
one parent or another because we may share a
particular trait that's visible or hidden, innate, or learned.
But it really raises a more interesting question. Why
do some of our traits looks like one parent,
and other traits look like the other? So if
you're familiar with your bioloical parents, who do you
think you most resemble? Check the box that applies.